I've got a game for you guys right now
we're gonna play a movie version of the
game would you rather so simply choosing
between the two options and briefly
explaining why you would choose one or
the other okay
first would you rather work with a
director who gives you too many notes or
not enough not enough - I was gonna say
too many not enough because I would love
to be able to give my own creative
effort it really depends on like where
he's coming from
this shouldn't be a long answer I'm
gonna say no it depends on the situation
because if the person is just like not
involved then that's uncomfortable then
you'd rather have someone's really yes
but you'd also not have someone who's
trying to control everything and really
be you know what I mean happy medium I'm
sorry would you rather have to run
throughout an entire scene or eat the
entire scene run run it's no fun you
kind of get your energy levels up I kept
thinking about the Twinkie see ya I'm
just watching it like wow because it's
not even like you could do the small
bite tactic no you're eating an entire
Twinkie yeah I think we probably like 20
pinkies and I even tried to like spit
them out we had we had to a system where
we you know someone came and we I spit
it out it was I wonder how that
individual was credited no this would
you rather work opposite an actor who
prepares way way too much we're not
nearly enough
again the trends I like I like not
nearly enough in some ways because I
think the most important thing is what
happens in the room in the moment yeah
and sometimes people can get locked in
the preparation that did on their own
and that's that's dangerous yeah I think
sometimes an over-prepared actor is so
stuck on the preparation yeah and the
imagination of that preparation that
can't be in the moment so I think I
would agree with
makes sense would you rather have to cry
in a scene or laugh in a scene I saw I
sometimes find it harder to laugh if it
depends who you're with and what's
happening because laughter is is tricky
it's it's such a mean crying obviously -
but it's so if it's your V V if you're
faking it you're faking it so like badly
so leave ability things seems like the
toughest thing to me and I you know I
want to laugh more than I want to cry so
yeah would you rather have to fake
sneeze or fake about it mmm definitely
the sneeze definitely the sneeze yeah no
vomits no vomited oh thank you but then
there's the convincing issues faking
sounds impossible to me I find it I
think losing I would like to learn don't
you do those little cute cat sneezes
isn't that don't you do that know
somebody but you know you just bring
that's because now you're at my mansion
yeah I don't say that okay
somebody does immortal engine oh really
but I think that's really cute you have
to learn to do really no no no you
should let it all go out because
sneezing for like ages would you rather
live on a traction city or in an air
town air air town definitely even with
what happens in this movie because I
thought the same thing but even getting
off the Jenny Oliver and stepping on
that plank the thought of taking one
teeny tiny step in the wrong direction
yeah okay here's me it does if you're on
the traction city and you can have like
at least air that goes down to the earth
and you can then be there then maybe
that's better maybe it maybe like Shango
in the mountains with the green yeah
it's purposely why I didn't
[Music]
you